we've known each other for a long time
and I've seen you through I think a a
dispassionate lens where I can say there
was this period in the Senate where you
needed to be serious yeah don't be funny
they said don't be funny and so don't be
funny don't be funny on the floor it
might be funny and hearings don't be
funny
uh don't be funny no jokes no sarcasm
because the other side whoever that is
can take that out of context just read
it well that was true of course that was
true but it was also more you won by 312
votes
right and people in Minnesota want you
to be want to know that you're serious
about this yeah and I went yeah no
and I didn't really internalize it at
first so I um
I tell the story well uh first day I'm
there I get sworn in go back to my
office first day in my office I've never
been you know take the subway back to
office go to the heart art building get
in my office there's a sheet on my paper
on my desk
set and I learned that one of your
duties as
a senator is to write congratulatory
notes to constituents and this first
note is to Ruth Anderson who's turning a
hundred and ten she's from Marshall
Minnesota she's turning 110.
so I've been told don't be funny so I
get out my official stationary use it
for the first time I write Dear Ruth you
have a bright future
[Laughter]
Shredder uh yeah close
my new assistant who I had never hadn't
met comes in oh I'd better but I hadn't
worked with her she takes it and brings
it to my new Chief staff who had
selected and uh he says what is this
and I said it's a joke yeah uh-huh
you think Ruth Anderson will find it
funny
I said I don't know she's 110.
he said do you think her family will
find it funny and I went oh yeah and I
started thinking about her 90 year old
son reading it
but see this is what I'm trying to get
to is for those of us who knew you and
you worked so hard at being a senator
and taking it very seriously and really
doing the work well of course yeah of
course but of course it was interesting
of course for me to see you I'm gonna
keep saying that of course it was
interesting to see you at that time
because uh I knew that you had to
restrain this whole other side of you
which was really funny because you can't
you really can't be doing that uh if
you're in the Senate and then now I see
that you're just back to hitting on all
cylinders comedically I'd say on three
out of fours
I'm trying to hit on all filmers oh it's
been great I've been feeling cylinder
engine and you're hitting on three
cylinders
three out of four but no I I think I'm
I'm hitting I'm doing uh
so two cylinders two cylinders you're
now down to two out of 12. oh boy the
car is smoking
that's not even moving yeah no I I mean
it was interesting like the second week
I'm there there's a supreme court here
and I'm on the Judiciary Committee and
Sotomayor
and Amy Klobuchar who's my senior
senator who's a Pros was a prosecutor
asked her like why did you become a
prosecutor and she said well I because I
watched Perry Mason as a as a and I
watch Perry Mason too and I so when it
got to me I just said why if you watch
Perry Mason a case a show in which the
prosecutor lost every case yes a
prosecutor and she goes actually Burger
one one case
yeah I was a prosecutor and so I said
okay well look I got 30 minutes of
questioning so let's get to that and
then at the end I had like I had about a
minute left and I couldn't develop a new
line of questions so I said okay as long
as we're at it what case
did Burger Perry Mason lose yeah and she
said I I don't know
and I said just because
I'm trained like you I just said didn't
the White House prepare you
which
okay prepare you on TV trivia
well she offered it as a piece of
information and then couldn't follow up
so that was very damaging but
uh and then but with the point about
that is I just got killed for that ah
real does Al Franken have to be funny
yeah yeah and it was as you know it was
just I didn't go okay I will ask her
yeah well I should became a prosecutor
because Amy hadn't yeah and then she
will say Perry Mason and then she'll say
well how did you become because hey
at what point because I know that you
you know your history well at what point
uh
did were we not allowed to be funny
anymore in our political discourse I
mean real politicism I'm not talking
about Wags on the sidelines but there
have been some there's a kind of funny
you're supposed to be right or can be
and sometimes it's funny like everyone
hates me because I say Lindsey Graham
was the funniest
say yeah Sona just hates me right now I
saw that you know I hate you I'm just
confused well uh I it is a quick sense
of humor he has a a sharp sense of humor
he does and his sense of humor is I'm
very cynical so I'll give you an example
I'm going to uh we're taking a break for
a winter vacation for Christmas vacation
and he says well you're going anywhere
take your family for son I said I'm
going to Vieques which is Puerto Rico
and he goes like do two immediately boom
do two fundraisers one for the people
for who are for Statehood one for the
people who are against they never talk
to each other
every one of his jokes is I'm the most
cynical guy in the world yeah and he's
proving that actually he has proven Day
Out